Trump busts the tyranny of the expert
class that's the focus of tonight's
angle the experts have been wrong on so
many things over the last few decades
think about it
they've been wrong on China they were
wrong on the Iraq war they were wrong on
Libya wrong on immigration and dead
wrong on trade President Trump has
promised to shake up the system on
behalf of the American people which he
repeated today the United States has
been taken advantage of by other
countries both friendly and not so
friendly for many many decades I'm here
to protect and one of the reasons I was
elected as I'm protecting our workers
I'm protecting our companies and I'm not
gonna let that happen
what are the GOP establishment expect
after he got elected that somehow Donald
Trump would become like one of them
Trump won by defying the conventional
wisdom of the establishment and he has
continued to do just that Donald Trump
in politics is an innovator and he's not
afraid to break with the establishments
orthodoxy to do what he thinks and his
best judgment is the right thing for the
American people but his own party's
fairly unimaginative old guard is
running to the same failed ideas of the
past that got us into the ditch we were
in and at the same time the left is
moving to the extremes and I would say
to the extreme irrelevance now just look
at the president's proposed daca deal
Democrats asked for amnesty for 800,000
dreamers ok well Donald Trump didn't
actually try to meet them halfway he
actually went toward them he raised them
a million as in amnesty for 1.8 million
illegal immigrants now I wasn't wild
about that offer frankly but it did show
Donald Trump's willingness to compromise
and frankly to get something done all
the Democrats had to do was agree to
border security and a wall and of course
to end the absurd policy of chain
migration
so to save the docket people like who
can refuse that deal well the answer is
the Democrats good because it would have
given Donald Trump a win and deprive
Democrats of a crucial campaign issue
well now the dreamers who've been
cynically used by the Democrats are
beginning to catch on
[Applause]
well those dreamers on Capitol Hill and
their supporters yesterday were
protesting Democrats well who knows
maybe they're tired of being pawns now
let's move to North Korea every time
Donald Trump issued a statement against
Rocketman or drop the sanction on the
regime the experts predicted an
apocalypse one of the things we've
discovered about this new president is
he has no clue about how to deal with
foreign matters he's dangerous and he
should not be talking with this kind of
bluster this is a mess that North Korea
has created but president Trump has made
it more difficult to deal with he is
doing none of the things necessary to
achieve a real diplomatic breakthrough
on North Korea now instead of their
promised apocalypse we have word today
that the president well I like to call
him President Kim Jong Cabbage Patch
doll is promising no attacks on South
Korea with nukes or conventional weapons
we'll see how it goes but North Korea is
signaling a willingness to hold talks
with the United States and considering
at least giving up their nukes you think
that that would have happened without
Trump's tough talk and reiterating that
all options were on the table never so
much for the experts now after decades
of bad trade deals let's move on to
another topic and hundreds of billions
of dollars in trade deficits Donald
Trump is trying something different he's
trying to level the playing field to
counter years of unfair trade practices
when it comes to steel and aluminum all
that dumping was going on all the
gluttons steel and aluminum he has
proposed tariffs on both steel and
aluminum imports as our steel industry
it's a fraction of what it once was
and we can't lose our aluminum industry
also a fraction of what it once was
well the establishment is in full revolt
there is a lot of concern among
Republican senators that this could sort
of metastasize into a larger trade war
we've had multiple conversations about
this he knows our view every now and
then we're just gonna have a different
approach on how we should tackle these
problems but it should be acknowledged
that there is a problem that needs to be
addressed here we just want to make sure
that it's done in a prudent way that's
more surgical so we can limit unintended
consequences
wait a second unintended consequences
are you kidding me
drive through Toledo Akron or the rest
of the Rust Belt you'll see ghost towns
you'll see a lot of people who believe
that guess what the government abandoned
them American manufacturing gutted
people who feel hopeless and you bet
there are a lot of people addicted to
opioids they didn't feel like they had
much option did they no matter the
fallout the establishment will always
lean toward unfettered unchecked global
trade White House economic adviser Gary
Cohen he tried to convince the president
to drop his tariff idea and to back down
I like conflict I like having two people
with different points of view and I
certainly have that and then I make a
decision but I like watching it I like
seeing it and I think it's the best way
to go I like different points of view so
he they battled it out in the Oval
Office Gary Cohen argued one point no
tariffs and other people Bob light hyzer
Wilbur Ross
they went for the economic economic
nationalist point of view
so Gary Cohen
worldview that lost out the populist
vision that won Donald Trump the
election won the day now this may have
been brewing for a long time with Gary
Cohen and let's face it working in the
White House getting hammered in the
media for your every move it takes its
toll it's not easy but from an
outsider's perspective it certainly
looks like Gary Cohen well picked up his
marbles and went back to goldman sachs
well we cannot stand by idly while China
floods our country with cheap steel and
dominates the global market think about
it this way in 2000 that was before they
became a member of the World Trade
Organization China accounted for 15% of
global steelmaking capacity by 2016
China had almost quintupled its share to
nearly 49% does anyone think for a
minute any of the experts think about
where China will be by 2025 and
steelmaking hmm consider the national
security implications of that you think
that they're going to make our tanks and
destroyers in a global conflict for us
the troubling thing is that when the
disestablishment is wrong as they have
been on China on tax cuts the illegal
invasion of our country they still lack
the humility to admit they were wrong
National Journal reporting today that
former President George W Bush compared
his administration to the Trump
administration Bush said sort of makes
me look pretty good doesn't it well
actually it doesn't
unless endless wars a financial crisis
unchecked immigration in leaving office
with the 28 percent approval rating is
pretty good
and by the way george w bush god bless
him love him great guy he didn't vote
for donald trump
so i frankly don't care what he has to
say about donald trump at this point in
time for eight years
george w bush the establishment of the
GOP was mute during the tyranny of the
obama administration
and now like Old Faithful he spouts off
at every opportunity to bash president
Trump either off the record or on the on
the record
resistance is not part of the solution
and repeating the failed policies of the
past it's getting us nowhere
so my message to the establishment of
both parties
we've tried your expert ways for decades
it led to the rise of communist China
which is now poised we don't turn things
around to be the dominant economic and
military power in the world now
President Trump sometimes it feels like
it's doing it all by himself is trying
to confront that threat and turn it
around before it's too late the
globalist critics out there don't seem
to care about what the freedom of the
American people whether it'll be
jeopardized our ability to chart our own
destiny our own course the way that
brought Donald Trump frankly sees it the
2016 election results and those
battleground states showed that the
Heartland was not ready to cede its
freedom to the gods of globalism those
people empowered the President to
protect their Liberty and restore their
economic independence and that's what
he's doing
the experts be damned and that's the
angle